the left has long blamed President Trump
for just about every political problem
under the Sun they've blamed him for the
Sun itself and how much it's heating our
planet that's par for the course
but Trump derangement syndrome has now
progressed to so advanced a stage that
the American Left is blaming President
Trump for schoolyard bullying we will
examine who the real bullies are and how
they get away with it
then postmodern Pete Buddha jej declares
that words have no meaning everyone
comes out as queer and president Trump
pardons a couple of jailbirds all that
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
they can't get them on the economy they
can't get him on Foreign Affairs they
can't get them on trade they so they got
to get him on schoolyard bullying that's
right that's what our terrible rotten
president is doing Washington Post
Washington Post just runs a huge article
news article Trump's words bullied kids
scarred schools quote the president's
rhetoric has changed the way hundreds of
children are harassed in American
classrooms the post found hundreds of
children first of all whenever I hear
the post found I start to discount it
then we're talking about a survey of
hundreds of children when 50 million
children in America go to public school
and many more children go to private
school in home school okay hundreds of
children they talk to here's how the
article begins to kindergarteners in
Utah told a Latino boy the president
Trump would send him back to Mexico and
teenagers in Maine sneered ban Muslims
at a classmate wearing a hijab in
Tennessee a group of middle schoolers
linked arms imitating the president's
proposed border wall as they refused to
let non-white students pass in Ohio
another group of middle schoolers
surrounded a mixed-race sixth grader and
as she confided to her mother told the
girl this is Trump country was that
Jesse Smollett was that girl is that a
smollett girl the piece goes on since
Trump's rise to the nation's highest
office his inflammatory language often
condemned as racist and xenophobic
condemned by whom by the post of course
goes on has seeped into schools across
America many bullies now target other
children differently than they used to
with kids as young as six mimicking the
president's insults and the cruel way he
delivers them I don't believe that I
don't believe the reporting I don't
believe the post
I think they act in bad faith I think
they lie all the time I think that this
article was just as likely written out
of the constantly revolving fiction in
its writers Minds as it did from
speaking to any school children now
that's true maybe some children are
being bullied in America there has
always been bullying for the entire
history of schools so I guess that
wouldn't be any different in trumps
America as it would be at any other time
the left is so deranged by Donald Trump
that they are now blaming him for
schoolyard bullying an eternal fact of
life by the way before we get into why
this is such BS by the way just as a
statistical matter schoolyard bullying
is actually down and it's actually down
significantly now how do you measure
schoolyard bullying that's obviously a
pretty difficult measurement to take
however in so much as we can take those
measurements and much more
scientifically than the post calling
some people around the country there is
a study that came out of the US
Department of Education
a recent study just showed the
percentage of students reporting that
they have been bullied has dropped by
more than a third over the last ten
years so bullying has not increased
because of Trump it's not a new epidemic
invented under Donald Trump schoolyard
bullying is actually down by about 33
percent ah look the left is going to
attack Donald Trump for anything and if
they can't find anything they'll make
something up but this question of
bullying is pretty important because I
think bullying defines a lot of our
politics today just not in the way that
the Washington Post says it does some of
Bernie Sanders's supporters have been
accused of bullying at Bernie Sanders
says this is ridiculous absolutely not
his is not a campaign based on bullying
it's a campaign based on love here's
Bernie what our people are involved in
we are a campaign which believes in
compassion which complete believes in
justice so I don't tolerate ugly attacks
against anybody but let me just say this
talk to the people in my campaign often
the african-american women in this
campaign talked to my wife about the
kind of ugly attacks that have come in
to us so right now which is a very
serious national problem we have an
Internet which is essentially the Wild
West
somebody could say hey I'm my Anderson
Cooper and zip I'll say some ugly things
and right now that cannot be stopped
did you catch that at the end at the
very end Bernie Sanders is implicitly
denying that his campaign is engaging in
any bullying he's saying look the
Internet's a crazy place a lot of people
can pretend to be a lot of people the
implication being people are pretending
to be my supporters they're pretending
to be me never mind by the way that
James O'Keefe a project very to us
caught Bernie Sanders campaign workers
on video saying that once the revolution
happens they're gonna send all the
Conservatives to the gulag that they're
gonna line them up on a wall and shoot
them those are you you we've played the
videos on this show before never mind
that we can see examples of Bernie
Sanders supporters saying they're gonna
burn Milwaukee to the ground if he
doesn't get the nomination nevermind the
left's bullying tactics as a matter of
course he denies it but when you get
past the rhetoric when you get past the
Washington Post a newspaper when you get
past the CNN debate stage you see that
bullying is the defining tactic of the
left we'll get to that in a second with
one particularly disturbing scene that
came out of Ohio University over the
last couple days first I got to thank
our friends over at Bambi when you were
running a business HR issues can kill
you especially in cases of wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations all sorts
of things that we just can't keep track
of all the time now HR Manager salaries
are not cheap the average HR manager
salary seventy thousand dollars a year
it's a lot of money it's a good line of
work Bambi can help you out Bambi
spelled B a.m. B e
e was created specifically for small
businesses you get a dedicated HR
manager in craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just $99 a month
dedicated HR manager $99 a month it's
unbelievable with Bambi you can change
HR from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated HR
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat go to Bambi comm slash
Michael right now schedule your free HR
audit that's Bambi comm slash Michael
BAM
baam vee calm / mi CH AE l check it out
Bernie says no way our campaigns based
on love nobody would bully okay the left
always bullies that is right now
probably the defining feature of the
left look no further than a video that
just came out of Ohio University
yesterday from the conservative activist
Caitlin Bennett Caitlin Bennett walks
into Ohio University mobs and mobs of
people throwing things at her screaming
at her pouring coffee on her and in my
favorite moment of it is when some SJW
gets in her face crazed hysterical steam
coming out of her ears and screams you
don't understand oppression think and
look I don't really know anybody very
well who's in that video but I think the
woman's screaming you don't understand
oppression I suspect she does not
understand oppression we had a bleep
battle out of that video just because of
all this crazy expletives and people
screaming and screaming all the time and
that conservative activist is Caitlin
Bennet from a quick Google search it
would appear that people on the internet
have very strong opinions about this
girl regardless of what your opinion is
if you're on the right left or Center
jut just actually take her out of it for
a second there just replace her were
they kind of like totally neutral figure
and look at all the people around her
look at all the leftists screaming
degrading themselves whipping themselves
up into a frenzy why I googled this girl
Caitlin Bennett do you know what her
great
as she took a photo in high school
holding an ar-15 and somehow this became
publicized and people lost their minds
over it that's it
took a picture holding a gun and now she
makes videos as a conservative activist
people go crazy
that obviously is bullying she's a
fairly petite young lady and you've got
these mobs of people men women giant
people kind of swarming around her
vandalizing her friend's car that is
bullying it doesn't just happen at that
college campus it doesn't just happen to
her it happens to conservatives all over
the country it happens socially there's
a ton of social bullying there's
obviously a lot of professional bullying
that's why people in big tech why people
in academia why people in corporate
America hide their political views
because they know that if they voice
their political views they're liable to
be fired they're liable to be
discriminated against there's a story
across the pond out of the United
Kingdom saying that the National Health
Service is able to deny non-emergency
care to people who make transphobic
comments whatever that means
you don't go along with the latest
leftist ideological fad you can be
denied health care now that's bullying
and of course there's the political
bullying which we see all the time and
we see it from left wingers who who now
want to make certain forms of thought
effectively illegal that's where the
bullying comes in now I want to make
sure that we get to some of these
candidates on the Democratic side
because Bernie Sanders says our
campaigns about love is whole campaign
is about bullying this whole campaign is
saying you can't do this you can't do
that we're gonna take away your money
we're gonna take away your choice we're
gonna vilify a whole class of people
used to the class of people used to
vilify was the millionaires and the
billionaires now it's just the
billionaires because Bernie Sanders
became a millionaire how convenient but
all of these get the whole ideology is
based on bullying it's based on do what
I say or else law be damned votes be
damned now they're the Democrats are
trying to tell us that there is a
radical lane and a moderate Lane well
moderates a relative term the moderate
is actually pretty radical itself and
Pete Moody judge showed that last night
so there was a CNN Town Hall I know that
nobody watched it I did not watch the
whole thing
it was unwatchable Peabody Jed showed up
and he told us once and for all there is
no moderate Lane in this race because
Peabody judge came out and said that
daca dreamers illegal aliens whatever
you want to call them are just as
American as Americans do you believe the
daca deserves a protective plan to
maintain daca permanently I do thank you
and I want you to know that I see you as
an American that you belong to this
country as much as anybody and I think
everybody here supports you too you're
not only contributing to your community
you're a taxpayer too and it is one of
the reasons it is so important to secure
the benefits of citizenship for you so
yes in the meantime we must reinstate
and establish daca protections but this
is also why we must no longer have this
hanging over your head and actually
solve with a pathway to citizenship in
which you are among the first to ensure
that that uncertainty is cleared up
because you know and again the American
people overwhelmingly agreed that this
is the right thing to do so that that
last part is not true the American
people strongly oppose amnesty even
Democrats oppose amnesty and it's a low
priority for the ones who want to do it
but that's not even my problem here he
says he wants amnesty he wants illegal
aliens to be able to become citizens I
mean he might as well have said more
importantly I want you to know that I
see you as a future Democratic voter
just as much as he could say I see you
as an American the radicalism here that
was not even on the amnesty the
radicalism is on that statement I see
you as an American you know you're
you're as American as anybody else if
foreign nationals are as American as
anybody
then the word American has no meaning if
the word American can refer to Americans
and not Americans then
no meaning to the word American it's
sort of like how we talk about the
redefinition of man and woman so man now
means person who is not a woman and also
sometimes a person who is a woman
according to transgender ideology so the
word man has no meaning and the word
woman has no meaning now it's the same
thing with American why does it matter
we'll get to that in a second first I've
got to thank our friends over at light
street I have a lot of friends and
family who do this they waste a whole
lot of money paying high interest credit
cards it is very easy right now with a
credit card consolidation loan from
light stream to take care of that rates
are as low as five point nine five
percent APR with Auto pay which that's a
much lower rate than the national
average interest rate on credit cards
the credit cards interest rates can be
20 percent APR you can get a loan from
five thousand to a hundred thousand
dollars with absolutely no fees you can
even get your money as soon as the day
that you apply this is how one of their
customers describes the experience said
quote I heard the radio ad and said it
was worth looking at I was a little
skeptical because I'd never done
anything like this before to my great
surprise the loan process was very
simple and easy to navigate through I
wish all loans were this efficient just
for my listeners right now apply to get
a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash Knowles lig HT s TR EA m.com slash
Knowles subject credit approval red
includes 0.50% auto pay discount terms
and conditions apply and offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lights dream.com slash knowles for more
information that kind of radicalism that
the word american can mean not american
to on the one hand it means there is no
chance that the democrats are gonna
nominate a moderate the media keep
playing up mike bloomberg we'll get to
that in a second we'll get to why
bloomberg as' is not really a moderate
either as of now Budaj edge is the
leading moderate and he is nothing of
the sort
Budaj is not just your average hike your
taxes kind of radical or soak the rich
kind of radical pete Budaj edge is a
words no long
have meaning kind of radical very
different thing and the left is
increasingly embracing this kind of
radicalism so they're not just saying
hey we're gonna take our policies in a
more extreme direction they're actually
saying words don't mean anything what
does American mean American means
whatever I say it wants to mean the one
place you see this most clearly I think
the one word they've defined into
nothing is actually one of their or
terms that they like to promote and that
is the term queer
what does queer mean rosario Dawson the
actress who was allegedly dating Cory
Booker but only while he was running for
president and now it's very unclear what
they're if they're dating or not rosario
Dawson just came out as queer but nobody
has any idea what that means she gave an
interview to bustle she said quote
people keep saying that I came out I
didn't do that this was a while ago I
mean it's not accurate but I never did
come out come out I mean I guess I am
now I've never had a relationship in
that space so it's never felt like an
authentic calling to me I know that's a
very mealy-mouthed vague and confusing
statement but when you break down what
she is actually saying it's pretty
shocking she says people say a long time
ago I declared myself a lesbian or gay
or transgender or bisexual or some some
part of the gender and sexual alphabet I
didn't do that I didn't do that in the
past it's not accurate I never came out
but I am coming out now but also I've
never had an LGBTQ LMNOP relationship so
it's never felt like an authentic
calling to me so she's saying I've never
had a queer relationship nevertheless I
am queer how is that possible replace
the term queer with the older euphemism
gay if I came out and said hey I've
never had a relationship an intimate
sexual relationship with a man I'm not
physically attracted to men I'm not I'm
not gay but I'm gay
that wouldn't make any sense whether
those are contradictory statements but
with the term queer it's soumil I could
come out as queer if I wanted to no one
would have any idea what that means
another actress Jameela Jamil this
actress came out as queer recently
because she was cast in an LGBT show and
she got a lot of flack for this because
they said you're not LGBT you're not
queer so you can't be in this queer show
and then she just came and said no I am
queer and how dare you forced me to come
out of the closet is queer but Jameela
Jamil is not queer by any meaningful
sexual definition of queer Jameela Jamil
is is dating James Blake who is very
much a man James Blake is he's like a
hot guy I don't as a straight man I
don't know if I'm permitted to use the
term hot guy maybe that makes me queer I
don't know I don't know because it's
very confusing but what I do know is
that this actress who's now conveniently
coming out as queer is dating a very
very much a man okay how is that
possible how's it possible that Cory
Booker's girlfriend and jameelah and
James Blake's girlfriend can both come
out as queer even though they're dating
men the word queer doesn't have any
specific sexual meaning the word queer
is just a means of claiming power it
does not refine oh it's considered a
sexual term it's the queue in LGBTQ but
it is not a sexual term if straight
people can be queer it's not a sexual
TIFF non Americans can be Americans
right then we're not referring to what
we think we're referring to the left
simply uses these terms to claim power
it's the same thing with American for
the left American does not have any
national meaning does not imply
citizenship in a country it's just a
means of claiming power so for the left
they think people that I like people
that I think will benefit me I will call
them American whether or not they are
American citizens or not other people I
will not call America
when it is convenient to me to call
myself queer I will call myself queer
that doesn't necessarily have to imply
any sexual meaning it's a radical
subjectivism it is a radical relat it's
just all about me it's all about my
desires and I can change it at any given
time that mayor Pete post-modern putas
judge applies the same principle to the
word Christians so that was the other
highlight of last night's CNN debate is
that we got a return of good old pastor
Pete gonna takes all the moralizing
bible-thumping judgmental aspects of
Christianity and just distills them down
into this kind of leftist pseudo
religion pastor Pete goes around and
tells people how what terrible
Christians they are specifically he
criticized unsubtle II the Christians
who support president Trump will be
afraid to talk about how my positions
are informed by my faith about God not
belonging to any kind of a political
party at the last TNN town hall you said
if your faith calls upon you to help the
marginalized those who are afflicted to
comfort to comfort people to strive for
humility and decency as the Christian
faith does and then I quote you then I
just can't imagine that that requires of
you that you be anywhere near this
president do you think it is impossible
to be a Christian and support president
Trump well I'm not going to tell other
Christians how to be Christians but I
will say I cannot find any compatibility
between the way this President conducts
himself and anything that I find in
Scripture now I guess that's my
interpretation but I think that's a lot
of people's interpretation and that
interpretation just
yeah I just can't find any compatibility
it's just so weird that the most
pro-life president in American history
who constantly is defending people's
freedom of conscience and freedom of
religion unlike his predecessor and who
has been uncommon ly honest in office
meaning that he does more of what he
says he will do than any of his
predecessors at least in my lifetime
it's so weird that Christians might like
that guy especially when he's running
against the party that is running on the
sacramental view of abortion killing
babies up until the moment they're born
and in some cases even after they're
born the party that is running on
redefining marriage beyond any sort of
coherence the party that says America is
a rotten no-good terrible place the
party that is embracing a radical
secularism the party that is now in many
ways worshiping the Sun yes so weird I
can't oh man I can't believe Christians
would support that guy you know the
other the other great advantage that
President Trump has by the way is not
constantly preening and prattling on and
spouting heresy and criticizing
Christians wrongly that of what terrible
people they are and and belittling them
for their faith I though that might be
why I think that might be why some
Christians prefer President Trump to
pete Budaj and and you by the way the
proof of the pudding is in the tasting
because most Christians in America do
support president from Pete Buddha jej
is not a moderate this is his worst
feature is pastor Pete his worst feature
is when Buddha jej goes out and
egregiously misinterprets the Bible and
one would have to conclude he's sort of
intentionally doing it just to use one
example Pete Buddha jej was on radio
when he was interpreting the Bible and
said that he found in the Bible
somewhere I'm not sure where a great
defense of abortion he said the way he
tried to defend this he said in the
Bible there's such an emphasis on breath
and so just when I think about babies I
think that before they take their first
breath it's totally fine to mash
come up and vacuum them out and chop
them up with scissors it's pretty much
what he said I'm not I'm I'm making more
clear what he said but the conclusion is
exactly the same obviously not biblical
egregious heretical blasphemous terrible
thing to say
and yet you don't see the write
regularly going out there and haranguing
Pete for his personal behavior saying
you're a terrible awful no-good rotten
fake Christian whatever he accuses
people of doing you don't see the right
bullying people to judge very much
you do see him wrongly incredably
incredibly bullying Christians on the
right he is not the moderate in the race
there is no moderate in the race Mike
Bloomberg isn't the moderate either and
you know people have been going after
Mike Bloomberg for these videos that
have been cropping up videos from his
past when when he was mayor of New York
and they're saying that's evidence that
Mike Bloomberg is a racial bigot I don't
think there's evidence Michael umbria is
a racial vidit bigot but I do think some
of these old videos are damning for his
campaign one in particular it proves
just about everything the right has been
predicting about the left over the past
ten or so years and Mike Bloomberg just
comes out and admits it we'll get to
that in a second first I've got to thank
our friends over at first leaf oh how I
love first leaf
I got started by taking the first leaf
wine quiz right when they came on as a
sponsor to assess my exact wine drinking
preferences you get to choose sweetness
wine styles even how adventurous you're
feeling and then I learned all about you
know what I like and they learned what I
like so what they do is they create an
introductory six pack of wine all for
just 29.95 six bottles of wine
2995 these wines normally go for at
least 20 bucks apiece when my bottles
arrived I taste it and I rated them his
first leave didn't totally believe my
own assessment of my tastes they sent me
some interesting ones which I'm very
glad that they did because I found out
that I liked some different wines and I
thought that I liked so I go on and rate
them and what makes it amazing is they
then start to match based on your ray
different wines that you might like I
love this thing after my freebie ran out
I've continued to subscribe I really
love this company they just they know
what they're doing where they ship more
than 17,000 unique wine shipments each
month go get it right now
sign up with my link you will get six
bottles of wine for 2995 plus free
shipping for a year go to try first
leave calm slash Knowles that is if you
rate all six bottles of wine from your
first bucks you get $10 off your second
box check out this exclusive offer only
at try first leaf calm slash Knowles
canna WL e s another video of Mike
Bloomberg this one's pretty bad this one
not not great Mike Bloomberg said in
this video that just cropped up that
government health care which all of the
Democrats are calling for means that we
need to deprive the elderly of care that
we need to push granny off a clip
furious all of these constitute going up
nobody wants to pay any more money and
at the rate we're going health care is
gonna bankrupt us so not only do we have
a problem
it's going backwards and we've gotta sit
here and say which things were going to
do in which things why not nobody wants
to do that you know you show up with
prostate cancer you're 95 years old we
should say go and enjoy have a nice
leave a long life don't you
we should do something about society's
not going if you show up with cancer and
you're in your 90s you should die and
we'll let young people get the treatment
because I'm Mike Bloomberg and I know
better than every single person on earth
how to live their lives thanks for
coming to my TED talk everybody I'm Mike
Bloomberg whoa man that's pretty radical
bad news for Ruth Bader Ginsburg I
thought the left is trying to do
everything they can to get a few more
months out of Ruth Bader Ginsburg no
Mike Bloomberg one of they're now
surging presidential candidate says Oh
somebody like Ruth Bader Ginsburg if
she's got health problems and she's
elderly yeah she's gonna we're gonna
tell her that's fine go live the rest of
your life and then go die we're not
gonna give you any medical care bad news
he Mike Bloomberg in this ways is
vindicating so much of what Republicans
and conservatives have been saying for
10 years we'll get to that in a second
but I want to bring your attention to
have possibly overlooked and highly
valued daily wire membership tear the
readers pass a readers pass gets you all
the articles ad-free including bench
bureaus beds which are exclusive for
daily wire members only you also get
access to our mobile app to read all of
our stories and receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content perfect when you want to
stay up to date on the go this is only
three bucks a month and if you're still
skeptical about it guess what we're
offering you one month for $0.99 mobile
ad free access to all of the daily wire
news exclusive op-eds from been and
breaking news and updates on our mobile
app all for the low low price of one
dollar check it out
you won't be disappointed go to daily
Wired icon we'll be right back with a
lot more
if you're elderly you're not going to
get health care under the Bloomberg
administration because only young people
are going to get health care this is the
height of technocratic liberalism this
is the height of some self-appointed
genius some self-appointed expert
telling people how their lives should be
run cradle to grave birth to death it's
based on this bizarre statistic that
keeps coming up in health care debates
which is that people spend half of their
lifetime healthcare expenses in the last
five years of their lives
duh of course they do when you're young
you're healthy you don't need to spend a
lot of money on health care before you
die you get sick when you are sick you
spend money on health care of course we
spend most of our resources during the
last few years of life that's when
you're gonna spend them but this is this
line that the left always uses has taken
as evidence that gosh if we could only
kill people five years before they would
otherwise die think of all the money we
could save it that's your campaign pitch
that's your is that gonna be your slogan
Mike Bloomberg throwing granny off a
cliff you know it's so frustrating as a
conservative because ten years ago when
guys like Paul Ryan and the kind of
reform akan fiscal Hawk guys when they
were proposing entitlement reform the
left was merciless they said they ran
ads on television which said that Paul
Ryan was trying to throw granny off a
cliff because he wanted to slightly
tweak Social Security he wanted to make
a few adjustments to Medicare
entitlements for people who are 50 years
old now but you know for when they get
to be 65 and this was considered killing
grandma now you have the surging
moderate candidate and the race
come out and say yeah we're gonna we're
gonna kill elderly people so that we can
keep more money for ourselves it also
proves something that the left or that
the right was mocked for for a decade
which is the death panels so you
remember when Obamacare came out
conservatives said Obamacare is includes
a provision of death panels and what was
meant by death panels was a government
board that was appointed to determine
whether or not you would receive health
care and if you did get health care then
I guess you got to live or you had a
good chance of it and if you didn't get
health care then you were going to die
conservatives dubbed these death panels
and the left mocked us for it roundly
were you crazy you think Obama cares
death panels what do you think Mike
Bloomberg is describing he couldn't put
it more clearly
he said elderly people are gonna come in
and then experts like me are gonna
decide based on how old they are or
whether we like the cut of their jib
whether or not they will live or die
it's no other way to describe it this is
inhuman you know I don't think that when
Mike Bloomberg talks about crime rates
that he's exhibiting some awful terrible
bigotry I don't think he's a racist or a
sexist or anything like that but I don't
think he respects people very much I
don't think he respects voters very much
and and I don't think he respects the
people that he governs I think he's a
nanny-state liberal scold technocrat who
has a very very poor understanding of
life and the philosophical issues that
undergird our politics and I think he's
just a kind of technical expert who
wants to make markets more efficient and
so one of those markets is healthcare
and if you want to make it really
efficient you got to kill people five
years before they would otherwise die
and okay makes sense that that totally
computes right if you're not a human
this is why Bloomberg would be a very
bad president it's also why Bloomberg is
a pretty bad candidate it's also why
there's no moderate in this race there
is nothing moderate about killing granny
so Joe Biden falling apart and he was
running to the left
even before he did fall apart reverses
his position on the Hyde Amendment says
that now people who were
lifers need to use their money to fund
abortions and not just any kind of
abortion late term abortions to Joe
Biden men comes out and says illegal
aliens are just as American as anybody
the same line that Peabody judge said
last night a line which means that words
don't have any meaning anymore and then
you have Mike Bloomberg the last
moderate left who says that we've got to
kill people before they cost us too much
money that's the party you know we
started the show on the Washington Post
accusing Trump of being responsible for
schoolyard bullying the left always
accuses the right of what the left
itself does and here's a pretty clear
example of that sort of in human
politics it's bullying I mean there's no
greater bullying than telling someone
they got to die you've got all the power
over them I mean that's that's a pretty
extreme form of political bullying and
that's what they're embracing it's a
politics of bullying and what's funny is
you get this very hardline politics on
the left and increasingly you're seeing
a little bit of a softer politics on the
right because yesterday President Trump
sprung a couple jailbirds from the clink
there were two major pardons that
President Trump announced yesterday he
pardoned Bernie Kerik who was New York
Police Commissioner under Giuliani he
was serving during 9/11 kind of a hero
in New York and rod Blagojevich the
former Democratic governor of Illinois
who tried to sell Barack Obama's Senate
seat after Obama was elected president
the guys thoroughly corrupt and Trump
decided to pardon Bernie Kerik and to
commute the sentence of Rod Blagojevich
so he didn't pardon Blagojevich but he
said that he can get out of jail he's
already been in jail for eight years and
I think he was supposed to serve another
six years in prison the left is furious
some people on the right or furious -
but it's funny that the left is furious
it's ironic because all the left ever
seems to one is decriminalization they
talk about it all the time the people
who want decriminalization of everything
are now furious that Trump
pardon to hero cop who cheated on his
taxes who's like relatively a pretty
good guy they're furious they're furious
that President Trump used his
constitutional pardon power to do this
and they're furious that Trump pardoned
one of their own guys at the former
Democratic governor of Illinois so how
should conservatives feel about this
beyond the irony of of left-wing
contradictions on this issue
how should conservatives feel my view
here's my extreme hot take it's fine
it's whatever calm down it's okay on the
one hand people should pay their debt to
society and people should stay in prison
on the other hand the Constitution gives
the president the pardon power for a
reason the presidential pardon power is
entirely legitimate it's right there a
clear as day in the Constitution and
part of this is because I was just
listening to homily from my priests the
Great Father Rutley about this and it's
an old idea he put it very well though
justice without love leads to tyranny
but so does love without just sort of
sentimentality right there's obviously a
balance that must be had here and so
president Trump is using that balancing
power that the Constitution gives him
and so now blue Goyo vicious family gets
to be happy his kid is a little older
it's nice that his kids and his wife get
to see blue guava CH Bernie Kerik
doesn't need to rot in a Cell anymore
Bernie Carrick is a hero cop he won a
ton of medals he's a local hero for 9/11
okay that's fine
the real question here is why did
president Trump do it and here's I think
why conservatives should be particularly
okay with the pardons what was in the
news before these pardons what was the
legal news that was dominating the
headlines the legal news dominating the
headlines was that former Trump campaign
advisor Roger stone is going to be
sentenced maybe to nine years in prison
for the unforgivable crime of working
for Trump and they caught him on lying
to Congress few things like that
then there was word that the DOJ was
going to try to reduce that sentence
then bill Barr came in and said
president Trump stopped tweeting about
this you're making my job much harder
then there were calls for investigations
of corruption that Trump is interfering
a criminal case that was the news
headline and Trump completely knocked
that out of the news just listen to the
press conference that Trump gave it was
a prosecution by the same people Comey
fitzpatrick the same group very far from
his children they're growing older
they're going to high school now they
rarely get to see their father outside
of an orange uniform I saw that and I
did commute his sentence so he'll be
able to go back home with his family
after serving eight years in jail that
was a tremendously powerful ridiculous
sentence in my opinion and in the
opinion of many others yes now listen to
that he's specifically talking about
Blagojevich here because Trump pardoning
Bernie Kerik who served under a
Republican and I served under a
Republican who's close to him Rudy
Giuliani that's not huge news
him him commuting the sentence of Rob
Blagojevich big deal big news story and
notice he gets in there yeah this was
done by James Comey this was gen but
done by the guys who came after me as a
defense he's reminding people that there
were these kind of illegitimate
investigations into Trump there were
these illegitimate prosecutions there
was an illegitimate impeachment really
uh really shrewd stuff he just used it
to kick the Barnstone stuff out of the
news and to remind people that the
Democratic Party and the left perverted
the wheels of justice to go after
President Trump and he wants to be able
to flip that narrative it's pretty clear
I don't see any other explanation for
his doing what he was doing and so I'm
perfectly fine with it I don't
particularly care about Rob Blagojevich
but the president has the legitimate
power to do that and if it helps okay
that's fine
in other news on great Justice around
the world Jeff Bezos richest man in the
world head of Amazon and the Washington
Post is giving ten million dollars
to fight climate change he posted it on
Instagram big picture of the earth and
how he's going to donate this ten
million dollars that's a lot of money I
think Jeff Bezos makes that about every
30 seconds but still it's a lot of money
for most of us mere mortals now of
course Jeff Bezos also owns a Gulfstream
g650 er private jet Jeff Bezos flies
that jet ported Lea 12 times per month
his company Amazon's carbon footprint
contributed more to greenhouse gas
emissions in 2018 then many of its
competitors in retail so doesn't seem
like he's exactly practicing what he's
talking about other than he gives he
writes a check but then he keeps up all
these practices that allegedly
contradict what he's supposed to be
doing
LaRoche Foucault said that hypocrisy is
the tribute that Vice pays to virtue but
I wonder if right here it's just a
little bit of PR or if it's a little bit
of empty religion if it's you know the
parallels between global warming and
religion have been pretty clear
you've got sin in pollution you've got
atonement in recycling you've got in the
sale of indulgences in the form of
carbon tax credits even NBC News last
year created a confessional for for the
climate you could go on to its website
and anonymously give your climate
confessions like you were going into the
box in the Catholic Church there are all
of these their secular Saints on
religion and the list goes on and on
that's the role that this is taken and
so in the olden days if Jeff Bezos
wanted some good PR he would have
donated to the church but now the modern
secular religion is global warming so
he's going to donate to that instead and
it's just this brought home to me a
tweet that started to go viral the other
night from a Twitter account called the
atheist forum and the tweet said this
said Christianity belief that one God
created a universe 13.7 9 billion years
old 93 billion light years in diameter
consisting of over 200 billion galaxies
each containing an average of 200
billion stars only to have a personal
relationship with you
which
more or less a pretty good description
of Christianity isn't that amazing isn't
that a wonderful thing God so loved the
world that He gave His only begotten Son
that whoever believeth in him might not
perish but might have eternal life
that's pretty good it's the gospel in a
nutshell right but I I responded to this
tweet and I I pointed out that atheism
is this belief that everything is
meaningless everything is sent senseless
like we were talking about earlier words
don't have any meaning it's just words
words words and we can't rely on any
sort of objective reality or our
arguments are unreliable they don't make
sense except conveniently the argument
for atheism that we can know for certain
atheism the theory that everything is
physical and everything that is not
physical doesn't mean anything except of
course for the non-physical argument for
atheism atheism is a belief that is
unsupportable it's contradictory and so
I at this ad and someone said to me you
know Michael look there are hundreds of
God's I just happen to believe in one
fewer God than you do and this this
misses the point the difference between
monotheism and polytheism is a
difference in kind it's not just that
monotheists have one God one you know
some fewer gods than the polytheists
it's that polytheism or paganism or
pantheism or whatever you want to
describe is fundamentally different than
monotheism which posits a God outside of
time and space who created all of the
creative things but an on another level
what this guy's saying is I believe in
one fewer God than you that's not my
experience my experience of atheists
having been an atheist for a while
myself is that it's not that atheists
believe in one fewer God then
monotheists it's that they believe in
many more guts than monotheists because
they they don't root their belief in a
God who is outside of time and space and
so they are given to all of the tempting
gods of this world money power fame sex
especially sex these days ego pride the
idea that you can redefine words to mean
whatever
you want them to mean like Humpty Dumpty
and
in through the looking-glass in Alice
and wonderland and it goes to this
fundamental worship of the creation
which we see in global warming obviously
Jeff Bezos is buying into that false
religion and the creation meaning
ourselves we are creatures were part of
the creation and that I think you're
seeing broadly throughout secular left
the idea that I can define reality for
myself Justice Kennedy wrote that in the
Planned Parenthood v Casey decision in
the early 1990s he said that we have a
right to define reality for ourselves
and of course the Democratic candidates
running for president right now say we
can define what the word American means
we can define what the word queer means
we can define man man or woman we can
just it's all about us but of course
that isn't true reality reasserts itself
in the end that is the great
conservative consolation as we were
talking about yesterday and we might be
bullied and bullied and bullied and
people might scream and shout in our
faces but that just doesn't change
reality
all right that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
get your mailbag questions in see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune into the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there